[Music]
today we have Aaron be burped
he is a documentarian who is working on
his new movie you don't know
nicotine set to come soon I hope it'll
be spring 2020
okay alright awesome I kind of want to
pick up where we left off my video which
is sort of explaining the very
contentious hot debate right now between
on the one hand you have vaping
advocates who argue for harm reduction
and then on the other side you have sort
of apparent it's it's a very contentious
topic talk me through trying to put
together a balanced documentary on that
and how if that's tricky what the
challenges are all of that well it's
very tricky because I mean there's been
you know basically a hundred years of
tobacco company influence in the topic
inside and then then of course
well-funded anti tobacco folks so you
got you've got a long rich history of
information worse here so it's very
tricky and a lot to unravel you've also
got a lot of entrenched positions and
the majority of us are kind of caught in
the middle here not exactly sure what's
going on with that so it's it's
definitely difficult one of the things
that we chose to focus on from day one
was looking at you know kind of this
situation where the teens and and even
younger kids middle school kids are are
now using nicotine devices whereas like
five years ago they weren't really doing
that so it's kind of an emerging topic a
lot of parents are extremely
uncomfortable I've talked to some
parents in fact one parent yesterday who
is telling me that you know her son you
know started using one of the dual
devices and you know things sort of
devolve from there so there's a lot of
concern and then a lot of ways a lack of
really consistent information the
scientific community has been has been
steadily gaining more research in this
but there's not exactly a a perfect
consensus in this and so yeah it's it's
tricky for sure that's probably why it's
taking so long
when I get it right
yeah and and it seems like what the
Surgeon General caught at that and also
the FDA Commissioner called both caught
epidemics is sort of an emergent
phenomenon I mean we didn't see this
I know 2018 was sort of the big year
where you saw this big spike in ecig use
but I think you've had sort of a unique
experience which I want to get to
because we can talk data all day but
you've been sort of on the ground a big
part of this is just talking to people
and getting getting the firsthand
stories walk me through what that's like
yeah well a lot of personal stories many
people have been you know things like
people have been opening up to us about
you know essentially internal family
struggles that they've been having with
this issue and so you know some of the
parents and kids have asked their faces
to be blurred because they want to speak
freely but you know it's uh it's been
it's been very tricky you know as well
as a lot of doctors and teachers that
we've talked to who don't really have a
lot of time to be doing scientific
research they sense you just kind of
need that the cliff notes on this so
they can get back to their jobs and you
know help take care of these kids so
that's been kind of a that's that's
probably been one of the biggest things
that I've learned is like parents
teachers even you know doctors just
haven't haven't had a lot of time to do
this and then when they do Google search
it it's a lot of kind of conflicting
information so that's that's what we've
been finding a lot of a lot of stress a
lot of extra you know not only an
epidemic of kids using nicotine vapor
products but also an epidemic of stress
that's been a big part of this where
your parents are just telling us that
they're almost overwhelmed by the
potential that their kids could be you
know dying from nicotine addiction and
that's something that they're very
concerned about so we're we're
definitely seeking out the top scientist
to make sure that we've got you know all
the bases covered talked to recently dr.
Neil Benowitz over at the University of
California San Francisco he kind of
walked us through this issue from a
scientific standpoint that was extremely
helpful I thought and we're really
looking forward to helping ease some of
those fears because I think that you
know the stress is a definitely a big
part of this so we want
reduce that and I think there's a weird
problem going on right now where what I
realize is I would watch some of these
you know ads from whether it be like the
truth initiative or whether it be from
the FDA themselves and it seems so
extreme but from a certain context that
it they're obviously trying to target
kids with these messages but then you
have when parents are google searching
you know FDA kids whatever they're
seeing worms go into people's brain and
they're thinking oh well this must be
what vaping is this is and so you have
this like double edge problem where on
the one hand you have like an attempt to
make very simplistic messaging that kids
will just like immediately grapple on to
I mean to give you an example of how
kind of crazy it is in at the end of one
of the commercials I saw there was a
cougar roar at the end of it to kind of
like you know to really nail home the
emotional you know the the punch of the
ad and I think that's one of the the
causes of the fears is you're sort of
seeing this an attempt at targeted
advertising but it ends up hitting sort
of sometimes the wrong demographics
right well yeah I definitely mean it's a
very emotional topic and so you see a
lot of different sides you know
essentially playing the emotion cards
and you know you've got the the pro
vaping folks on the other side talking
about everybody dying if they don't have
all the vaping products and then you
have the you know some of the health
groups claiming that everybody's gonna
get brain worms on the other end so of
course that's very tricky you know it's
it's been interesting this movie is
definitely gonna be a fascinating one
because we've you know we've just been
uncovering a lot of things you know it's
been it's been very interesting yeah and
you're having to sort of in a way
straddle those two interest groups and
really talk to both sides meanwhile it
feels very tribal to me one of the more
tribal topics that I've ever covered
where where I'm talking to people and
it's it's hard it's really hard to get
them to open up if they think you're on
this side or on this side or they're
really trying to identify where you fit
where do you think your movie do you
think your movies sort of trying to
talk to both sides yeah that's a great
question well we've tried to talk to
both sides and unfortunately a lot of
the pro vaping folks have decided that
we're against what they're doing so you
know we've had a lot of you know a lot
of I'd say online bullying to some of
our accounts it's been interesting in
that way we've had some really good
talks with some of the health folks so I
would say you know in some ways that you
know our goal though regardless of who's
talking to us is as always really to get
the truth out there and and take time
you know one of the things I try to do
is really deeply listen you know there's
it's a lost art form you know listening
you know and if you listen to both sides
with your heart you can kind of see what
are the real issues involved here you
know parents don't want their kids dying
from nicotine you know health folks you
know that's their job to protect the
population you know folks that are in
smoking cessation
you know organizations like their goal
is to help people quit smoking so
everybody has kind of what they're
trying to do a lot of what's being said
of course is very confusing but you know
we're gonna try to nail it as best we
can again using science but also using
our hearts to and really just making
sure that we're listening to the core
issues and kind of addressing those
before throwing you know dead at people
because data usually doesn't do a lot
yet just just data overloading someone
and it seems like both sides sort of
have their data something I wanted to
talk about and sort of get your a quick
take on because it's something that I've
been sort of wrestling with is it seems
like one of the places that for me the
breakdown is occurring is over this word
epidemic and there's so much contention
over this word you know I I have so many
I've tried to follow as many Pro vaping
and you know like vaping control I don't
know what you'd call it
tobacco control people as I could and it
that was one of the most hotly debated
topics because I think everybody's for
kids not vaping I mean the only thing
I've ever actually met anybody ever who
is like you know I'm really just for
kids vaping nicotine I've never heard it
so it seems like so it seems like the
breakdown is actually in this like weird
splitting a
hairs of like what what is an epidemic
and then you'll see like very selective
charts being formed and this gets to
your point about data not overloading
someone with data because everyone
seemingly has you know how they can
cherry-pick the data to fit this
narrative or this narrative I try to
focus on look no matter who's side like
no matter where you think the data
exactly Falls we can all agree the kids
should not be vaping and that we should
be trying to make it harder for kids to
vape when they're underage what do you
think on that side is like do you have
any thoughts about some stuff that is
very common sense or because I know
they're really far-reaching policy
people on both sides ban everything
don't ban anything at all or make no
regulations on it where do you sort of
like fall maybe not even in the movie
but personally or how do you feel
because you're a parent - yeah I'm a
parent I've got a middle-school daughter
and a son who's about to be in middle
school so I mean this stuff is coming at
us hot and heavy a lot of our parents
groups are discussing it you know
there's a lot of a lot of concern out
there so I think for you know for me
personally and of course the movies not
done yet we're gonna rely on that the
you know the thinkers that's primarily
focus on this you know we're gonna take
leadership from those guys some because
a lot of them that we've taught you have
spent a lifetime of researching this
topic but personally you know for me
coming from you know as a film director
I've also directed a lot of commercials
I did study advertising and in my
undergraduate and you know I understand
that topic pretty well one of the things
I think we need to do is is think about
marketing you know and and how does you
know a lot of people have told me they
believe these products are adult
products I also agree with that there
are dot products but a lot of them are
being marketed is like in a fairly
juvenile way you know and and for me I
think one of the things we could do to
kind of help ease that stress and help
reduce the situation with with kids I'm
looking at these things would be perhaps
just to look at some marketing
restrictions another thing that would be
good I think they should definitely ban
sales in every city state country around
the world for underage you know for for
any
I'm an adult you know I think that's
common sense and I would urge you know
governments around the world to do that
another thing they think should should
probably be you know looked at is where
are these kids getting these things you
know if they're a parent told me that a
lot of the kids are going to you know
one of those essentially some sort of a
poorly run kind of dingy convenience
store and that'll sell people just about
anything because they need the money you
know we need to enforce these laws so if
we're gonna say it's it's illegal to
sell that to kids under 18 then we need
to actually enforce those laws and right
now I don't think the laws are being
enforced and I think that's a that's
probably the biggest issue right now and
you know people are getting caught up in
a lot of other issues but ultimately I'm
and we're just not enforcing the laws
that are already in place and then I
would say fourthly and this is something
we're actively trying to do I mean I'm
I'm pleased that you're also taking on
this topic is really just educating
families and kids about that I think a
lot of times we treat kids like they
don't understand things yet these are
oftentimes the people doing science
research papers you know they're
researching things this is what they do
I don't have to do a lot of research
papers although I guess in some ways I
still am doing that but most parents
aren't doing research papers that don't
you know there's a lot of new ways to
learn things I think these kids are
learning things so ultimately we just
need to be a part of that conversation
and help steer them away from using
nicotine while their brains are still
developing so I think if you do those
four things kind of have a really just
solid conversation not based and hype
they're really just based in facts I
think we're gonna find that you know
this this whole situation can can begin
turning around here pretty quickly so
that's I'm kind of optimistic about that
I agree and one of the things that I'm
sort of always thinking about and I'm
hoping that at least my little mini
documentary gets across and I was hoping
you'd weigh in on it is I'm pretty
concerned about when we sort of
infantilized our kids that in the long
run that hurts their trust in public
health and it damages that sort of
belief that the government's giving so I
don't know I worry that that when
when we when we make commercials that
are targeted on the one hand for a very
quick punchy takeaway and they do give
that that there might be some like side
effects down the road do you worry about
that at all yeah I do worry about that
you know I know there's a lot of really
great folks on public health that are
trying to you know write big issues but
I do sometimes wonder if you know
there's some sort of disconnect there
with with some of the things that I've
seen I know even though I understand
what they're trying to do you know the
City of Pasadena Health Department was
essentially dressing people up as sheep
and telling people not to be sheep you
know which you know there's some of
these things that it's just like you
know I don't think creating harm you
know we're stigmatizing people is
probably going to be the way to get this
thing fixed you know so I guess in some
ways I disagree anytime that you're you
know your name calling or
oversimplifying very complex issues I
think that could be kind of an issue
even though I understand they're trying
to target the kids oftentimes I think
the parents are the ones we probably
need to be speaking to because they're
the ones that you know ultimately we
need talking to the kids you know
they're the ones that have the kids on a
daily basis generally speaking and so
yeah I do worry about that you know I'm
excited to be a part of it you know do
you know helping get the the truth about
nicotine out there to kids and to
families and to teachers but we got to
do it in just a really sensible way I'm
really a big advocate for that so I want
to ask you first what do you think is
something that vaping advocates should
know that you found in your research
that you think you know what there's
probably not enough attention on this
and then on the other side what do you
think that the parents of teens or teens
should know that maybe is not being
talked enough on that side if you could
talk across the aisle to both sides real
quick yeah one of the things you know
lately I've been really seeing you know
you want to talk about the pro vaping
folks I would say that one of my biggest
things to them would be you know you
just need to be nicer people you know
been seen just a lot of just anger on
that but that's kind of I guess the
secondary thing one of the things that
I've been here
- is some folks saying like these
products are harmless or like you know I
mean or nicotine is harmless like well
it's not harmless you know there there
was a very young girl that died in
Australia recently because she was
drinking her mom's essentially kind of
raw supplies this mom was making her own
vaping liquid and the daughter grabbed
it when she was looking and drank it and
unfortunately the daughter did did die
from that so it's really important that
we don't minimize things that have
happened you know the truth is that
nicotine if taking in in the wrong
dosage is deadly like that's a fact so I
would advocate for people to to make
sure that we're not leaving sort of raw
nicotine laying around that usually only
happens in Australia or Brazil in
countries where where they banned the
sale of these products so it's kind of a
black market situation so that's not
very typical but nevertheless we know
that it's not not harmless okay we know
that's true and so it's hard to have an
honest conversation with someone who
just wants to tell you something's
harmless when ultimately you know that's
just not true so that would be my advice
for those folks you know stick to the
facts I'm trying to take the emotion out
of it have a real conversation with
people don't don't attack people that's
not usually gonna help the discussion so
that would be my advice for them for
another folks who are parents is that
what you're talking about or which folks
well I guess parents and public health
policy makers yeah well one of the
things I would say with for public
health folks I think some of the
questions need to probably be answered
for the adult side of it I know that's
still something I'm personally looking
at what you know what is the case on
that there's obviously people very angry
group of people out there who don't feel
like they're being listened to you know
I personally am against tyranny of the
majority I just think ultimately what we
have in a very divided country in a very
divided world right now is where when
people get a little bit of power perhaps
they don't listen to the other side you
know I don't know all the answers but I
do know these folks are very angry and I
don't think it's because they're being
paid to be angry I've seen people
dismiss them
you know as is fake activists I don't
think that they're fake activists you
know I've tried to have good
conversations with me with these folks
sometimes it doesn't go very well but
nevertheless they're not fake they're
very passionate about this and you know
I think that they need to they need to
be listened to I think we need to be
careful about some of the potential
policies because a lot of these things
have unintended consequences and you
know I think that some of those
unintended consequences we just have to
be very careful that we aren't inviting
additional consequences simply because
we haven't thought through all the
actions but so yeah I guess that would
be my my side kinda from the middle most
of most of us parents say most people
are in the middle you know we're just
looking at all the sides and we're
saying you know could we could we get
some evidence-based answers here and
could we you know kind of move forward
on the situation yeah I mean absolutely
in a way a lot of the the vaping
advocates are just seeing the other side
of things I've long felt that like
smokers are definitely were one of the
more persecuted groups and I think
because of that a lot of vapors end up
our X smokers and so I think you end up
with a lot of the feeling of like well
you've you've told me to quit you've
told me to quit you've told me to quit
now I've quit why are you trying to take
away my so I I really I I agree with you
I see I see that side I and I also see
the side the parents as well it's a
really tough issue you're trying to
tackle here a few more questions and
I'll let you go yeah I'm from I think
you actually hit on something really
interesting which is and and you talk to
actually about it on the top there's
this legacy of smoking that is
unfortunately carried into vaping where
there's there's not a lot of trust so
when I saw Philip Morris I found this
fascinating their international twitter
account has like help us go smoke-free
and it's like that is a crazy statement
if you think about it if they're being
you know if you take them at their word
that is a wild claim they're basically
saying we want to put ourselves out of
business for this new business
for a for public health reasons I know
there are varying levels of skepticism
you know and all that kind of stuff but
should we embrace big players like that
who have the because I know like quality
controls a huge problem should we
embrace big players who could bring
quality control who could bring these
kind of things to the table or do you
think we're gonna see a huge resistance
to that just because of where they've
been for so long well you're gonna get a
lot of resistance to that and you know I
think that's something where you know
anytime I'm dealing with the topic in
any topic where there's really large
players and in place specifically with
pharmaceutical industry or government or
in this case you know giant tobacco
companies now you have to be extremely
careful you know you have to have your
eyes wide open you know and I think you
know historically you know these big
tobacco players were not a part of you
know some of the vapor technology early
on right think you know you had a lot of
smaller smaller folks you know
mom-and-pop shops and you know it's
essentially a big giant cottage industry
until jewel kind of came to town you
know I think those smaller folks have
done pretty well you know you don't see
a lot of you don't see a lot of deaths
or disease from from you know the the
current you know group of vapor products
out there for you know folks that are
using those and so I don't know if you
necessarily need Big Tobacco to come
save the day right now I think the real
key is just figuring out you know the
the levels of safety officially stating
those giving parents information so that
they can talk to their children about
this you know I think that's probably
the big key right now is we need we need
more information I don't think Big
Tobacco specifically just got the right
history or interest lead that effort I I
actually agree I don't think they're
gonna be able to overcome that just no
matter what their intentions are for
good or for bad well thank you so much
for coming on I really am
grateful that there's someone else who's
doing a really proper job at this I only
can research you've been doing this for
I mean how many months have you been
working on this movie it's been quite a
while yeah it's been a while at least
nine months officially so yeah it's been
a lot of research I always love to talk
to people who've really done their due
diligence so I'm really excited to see
the movie it's coming out
spring 2020 is that right spring 2020
and people could check out teaser if
they just search for you don't know
nicotine on YouTube Facebook Twitter
it's kind of pin to the top of all those
pages so people can check out that I'm
kind of get a sense of what we're headed
towards and yeah we look forward to
having people sign up to get emails and
kind of stay updated on the topic it's
an important one Thank You Erin I really
appreciate it I know you're one of the
people really listening to both sides so
it's awesome yeah you bet thanks I
appreciate you
[Music]
[Music]